[Music]
a very somber friday here at 8 news now
as we remember a long time member of our
family gary waddell he passed away
thursday evening thank you for joining
us i'm kirsten joyce and i'm christian
casadez gary was not only a beloved
member of our family he was a fixture in
living rooms across las vegas as a main
anchor for 32 years
8 news now anchor brian loftis looks
back at the life and legacy of gary
[Applause]
during his 32 years at klas gary waddell
was known for his honesty and calm
demeanor on the air and his leadership
and mentorship behind the scenes he
spent many of his three decades at the
station sitting alongside paula francis
i get it
as often as anything else
that
when bad things are happening you and
paula make me feel like it's going to be
okay denise valdez sue lowden and george
knapp on the evening news where news
comes first now gary waddell the
newscast anchored by gary and george won
upi's newscast of the year in 1986.
he was loved by everyone at the station
gary covered many of the events and
moments that left lasting impacts on our
city from the mgm fire in 1980 the
latest reports are that the fire is out
to the pepcon chemical explosion
at this morning's nevada delegation
meeting and brought us coverage from
national events like the 1996 democratic
convention in chicago and following
along with nevada's task force one as
they rescued people trapped in louisiana
by hurricane katrina in 2005. gary
arrived in las vegas in 1971 as a tv
reporter moving over to channel 8 in
1980 until his retirement in 2012. my
favorite line i think is don hewitt's
when he talks about 60 minutes and and
the reason for 60 minutes and that is
tell me a story
and and from then to today that is still
the hallmark of this business his name
will forever be remembered as a
respected and iconic journalist in our
great city he was the longest serving
newscaster in las vegas history gary is
in the nevada broadcasters hall of fame
the klas hall of fame won a slew of
broadcasting awards and even has a
street named after him outside of work
gary loved riding his motorcycle he even
worked at a harley shop after he retired
and anyone who stopped by his desk
remembers his faithful pet tarantula
frankie i'm really going to miss being
i'm really going to miss being in the
center of the action when that's why
we're in the world
and we are going to have much more
coverage throughout the afternoon and
evening including a conversation with
paula francis ted you of course worked
with gary for some time
yeah um i think my fondest memory
was uh when i got here in 2004
they put me right at the weather there
was a monsoon storm going yeah i
couldn't pronounce a hualapai i couldn't
pronounce grand teton
but i was covering whether the best i
could i did a horrible job right and
then gary comes over me after the show
and i was like distraught because i was
like how did i do
and he goes without a word just he goes
ted
great job
and you can do even better tomorrow
[Laughter]
thank you for sharing that ted